I wrote it I sent it I think it's
important to first address that I'm sort
of a piece of on Twitter because
mostly what I do on there is just pick
out people I don't like
and then just badger them and harass
them until they're either forced to
respond to me or do the smart thing and
completely ignore me like in the past
I got an argument with Tom Hanks's
rapping son Chet haze and also the food
franchise soup plantation because that
name is racist period but the one that's
most important to me is garbage person
Chris Brown on May 5th I tweeted it's
Cinco DeMayo so when you're beating up a
pinata keep in mind it's also Chris
Brown's birthday Chris Brown once
tweeted do you know Chris Brown which is
a question I still don't understand but
I retweeted it and put is what
detectives ask all your girlfriend and
sometimes I get political like I tweeted
Mike Pence running with Donald Trump is
like the time Chris Brown did a song
with pitbull so again I just send these
out mindlessly I'm an idiot and then I
look down at my phone and it said Chris
Brown is now following which is normally
something that would make a woman run to
a police station and then a minute later
I got another email that said you have a
direct message from Chris Brown so I
open it up and it just says plainly in
two words you make sense but Chris Brown
was smarter than I was he went back into
my Twitter and liked over 200 of my
tweets which kind of thought was nice or
cute but then I realized Chris Brown
fans are so maniacal and fanatic that
they look at everything he likes so
immediately they were like why would
Chris Brown like two hundred tweets from
a guy who looks like a Verizon
spokesperson and the answer was because
then they can harass me back so for
almost two years I would get tweets it's
a few team breezy over and over again
you know what I deserved it protip Chris
Brown doesn't only fight with his fists
he also uses his Twitter fingers
you